uh fox news propagandist sean
hannity is trying to push donald trump
even further
on these corrupt pardons we know that
donald trump is already considering
preemptively blanket pardoning
his attorney uh rudy giuliani
he's considering pre-emptive pardons for
his son-in-law jared kushner
and three of his children ivanka don jr
and eric
but rudy giuliani on his radio show this
week i'm sorry
sean hannity on his radio show this week
suggested that donald trump
should really pardon himself as well
because everybody's just so unfair and
terrible to trump and they might go
after him when he's out of office take a
listen this is actually from an
interview
that sean hannity does with sydney
powell and it's fascinating that even
sydney powell who's completely deranged
has to say you know self pardons i'm not
so sure about that take a look
unfortunately i'd estimate that five to
ten percent of our prison population
right now is not
guilty but the system did not work as it
should have to exonerate them and we've
got to do a better job of that
not everybody can get a presidential
pardon
well that's a good point and you know i
watched andrew weissman come out and
literally say oh
biden's a.g needs to go after donald
trump
and i'm like the president out the door
needs to pardon his whole family and
himself because
they want this witch hunt to go on in
perpetuity
they're so full of rage and insanity
against the president i mean it's
can can the president i i assume that
the power of the pardon
uh is absolute and that he should be
able to pardon anybody that he wants to
it is absolute it's in the constitution
i don't know about his authority to
pardon himself
but it should not be necessary and aside
from that the president's going to get
another four years in
office to finish the job he started
because the election fraud we are
uncovering
is massive and there were foreign actors
involved in
our system that's actually really funny
um
even completely delusional deranged
attorney sidney powell has to mention
you know sean i'm just not totally sure
about trump's ability to pardon himself
uh and and that's actually uh an
important detail now
sydney powell is saying lots of crazy
things here so is sean hannity powell
saying
trump actually won powell's saying
trump's going to get another four years
but she does mention trump pardoning
himself
is a question mark and the new york
times had a really good write-up on this
issue
remember that donald trump has claimed
that he can pardon
himself he tweeted back in june of 2018
which seems like
a decade ago quote as has been stated by
numerous
legal scholars i have the absolute
right to pardon myself but why would i
do that
when i have done nothing wrong in the
meantime
the never-ending witch-hunt led by 13
very angry and conflicted democrats
continues into the midterms trump can
pardon his friends and allies there's no
doubt about it
trump can pardon people before they are
even charged a preemptive pardon
is certainly something trump can do
trump cannot protect people from
state charges it is very much
in question however whether a president
can pardon himself or herself
and it's never been attempted now there
are legal opinions on both sides
on the yes side a president can pardon
themselves
the argument is the constitution doesn't
say anything about a limit there
the constitution says nothing about you
can't pardon yourself
the constitution does say if you if a
president is impeached and convicted
they can't pardon themselves from an
impeachment conviction
so the interpretation from some legal
scholars is listen
it's very clear that when there was
meant to be a limit the constitution
mentions the limit
the constitution mentions a president
can't pardon themselves from an
impeachment conviction
so we can infer from that that if
the founders intended a president would
be unable to pardon themselves from
federal crimes it would be mentioned
since it's not mentioned a president can
do it
that's one interpretation okay now on
the other side there are many counters
one counter is the constitution says the
president can
grant a pardon and this is a sort of
linguistic analysis
the word grant means from the president
to someone else and so the presence of
the word
grant means a president can't pardon
themselves that's one argument
another argument on the the president
can't pardon themselves
side argues that a principle in all
law nationally federally at the state
level there's a principle in law
that you cannot be a judge in your own
case and that
a self-pardon would effectively be the
president being a judge
in his or her own case so the simplest
situation as has been discussed is
instead of trump pardoning himself and
maybe being subject to legal challenge
the simplest
path forward that has been floated is
trump resigns
shortly before the end of his term mike
pence
becomes president mike pence pardons
donald trump
uh no doubt about it that would be far
simpler i still
don't think that that is actually going
to happen but it would be interesting to
be wrong on that one and if it
if i am wrong and donald trump does
resign in order for mike pence to
preemptively pardon him uh that will be
one of the biggest
political history stories uh certainly
for decades to come
later on today we are going to talk
about international reaction to the
continued voter fraud claims being made
in the united states and
international reaction to joe biden
continuing to move forward with his
incoming administration we are also
going to talk i got a lot of emails from
people saying david do you think tucker
carlson is the direction the republican
party will go in in 2024
and i have some thoughts about it which
we will discuss a little bit later
and then we also now that the
presidential transition has formally
been started the gsa saying we are
releasing these 7.3 million dollars
in funds to joe biden to officially
start that transition
we are going to address the question of
whether presidential transitions
should even depend on a sitting
president but there's a second layer to
that question which is do they really
even depend on the sitting president
because remember
whether or not the transition funds were
released to joe biden
donald trump stops being president on
january 20th at noon eastern time either
way
so all of those questions and your calls
are upcoming
we've got a great program for you today
let me know what you're following what
you're paying attention to
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
we will take
a very quick break and be back right
after this
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called teddy stratford i love
these shirts and that's why i asked them
to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap in
the chest where the buttons are
you don't get that with the teddy
stratford shirts because all of their
shirts come with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons
which prevents the chest from stretching
apart like that but most
importantly just overall it makes the
shirt fit
much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt
is also cut in a way that improves the
look of your upper body physique it has
a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you
it also has a specially designed collar
that won't
fall down and lay flat which i love the
difference
all around with these shirts really is
noticeable go check them out at
davidpakman.com teddy the link is down
below and they'll give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout